i want to read a part of the letter that
you posted on your instagram
account in december 2020 okay yeah
and you wrote hi friends i want to share
with you
that i am trans my pronouns
are he they and my name is elliot
i feel lucky to be writing this to be
here
to have arrived at this place in my life
i feel overwhelming gratitude for the
incredible people who have supported me
along this journey i can't begin to
express how remarkable it feels to
finally love
who i am enough to pursue
my authentic self
so can you describe the weeks and the
months
and maybe even the years that led up to
you posting that letter what were the
factors that help you
make that monumental decision
goodness i mean definitely
uh obviously quite the journey i'd say
leading up to it
and the months before what i really had
was a moment for
myself um where and this is obviously
quite a privileged thing to say but i
wasn't working um because of the
the current situation we're in with the
pandemic and
i was up in nova scotia and i spent
a lot of time just by myself
and i think it really allowed me sort of
separating from
you know that world so to speak for a
moment
to really get to
sit with myself and certain
[Music]
aspects that i had never given myself
the opportunity to do
and i think that was definitely on
purpose to a degree
even though i wasn't necessarily aware
of it just
you know avoiding so much in a way the
busyness of life
allowed and has allowed most people
to not to look inward and so what you're
sharing is is that
you had this time alone and were you
physically alone
i was pretty alone in nova scotia yeah
like
out i mean seeing people of course too
but really purposefully was
is probably the first time in my life
where i
really felt okay and comfortable alone
it used to just be
incredibly difficult for me to even just
sort of sit with myself
um and this was a time where that was
possible
and really uh
relax and let my body relax i think i
realized getting to that space and and
getting surrounded by nature more
it almost was like steps into relaxation
it was like i would notice my body
sort of go into that space more and more
and i think on some level it probably
allowed me to connect to my body in a
way that
i i could really fully listen to myself
and i think for so long i
didn't even have a concept of what i was
feeling you know
you